okay babies HFR psychobabble um and we
are back at it we're back at it again
like it you know like what I see gonna
head out um okay I want to say okay
we're gonna do this contract question
right here see what the lady says a big
one Jenny of the woods
Jenny the woods okay dude Jenny I that
want that say this I'm level three is
that like really mad and I guess at what
where is that right Raj actually pretty
close okay well check it out I knew I
saw that what I was doing there today is
Jenny is that how are we talking to know
I'm here for a Jedi yeah Jen I hair gel
hair at the Nana's ex new light on me
here
let's talk about my rewards a lot a lot
[Music]
yeah bad bank let's do this okay so
let's get this coffin Wow I just want to
hard for me it's got that skull again
this is probably all like why you'd
offer me but I well you know that I
gotta I'm here for you I want so head is
like is in a make up in this land just
kidding
that's horrible okay yeah
grin tips a mess like mmm-hmm he shares
on a cloud
just after it's like okay I need some
frickin food wait let me just quickly go
this thing and try and get some like
food or something
Marcin there we go no I need some fat
yeah a fat idea what is that go end card
well I'm not here for like your Gwent
stuff I need some food dad saddlebags
uncommon 183 right yeah I got John Kerr
wait maybe I have stuff any freaking
food now
and okay I got a crab something can I
get some frickin found here
what's decoction okay I guess I'm gonna
this I get again with no frickin food
and it's fine you know
I was actually really that interested I
guess and fed you know can I say like
berries or something I can't wait I have
so much food
here's the other right
here can I eat this get all this stuff
I'm getting dressed on okay let me just
kill this thing over there
you know host entries that it has it
okay we check on any which are sad says
what is that bear fun check this out I
ain't some freaking fed
where the hair we go
Jesus Christ I guess I'm gone back here
anything notable on here
I hear dog friggin like growling
couldn't outrun her pursuer he stabbed
her or slit her throat there it is yes
that's what I'm talking about
what happened to the trackpad I went
this way
even though I told them I don't want to
know him I know that afraid to poke up
but I ant he loves me okay
inventory wise though he's nothing on it
is on okay so now I can kill like deer
and stuff I need air out here
are they bad
crabby of their bed they're bad okay
didn't get him Jesus he sounds like so
hard to kill okay anyway let's continue
such a good
can't say for sure but the youngins they
totally clearing mostly west of the
village pasture fields and a cat can
some frickin food that meat yeah
okay looking around a meeting here oh
yeah oh good oh good
Oh oh yeah yeah good good
ignite there we go burn the ladder
it's as
all right and I guess we're gonna do
this so don't get jacked up on this
maybe I should love life a lot better
hey gob a bang
there we go
there we go oh yeah
yeah she said way whoa she's actually
like jacking me up face jring vulnerable
against ba oil in the yard in signs okay
that wasn't okay yeah why doesn't take
on oh yeah
guess I'll say I guess we'll say
let's kill this fall got out don't shut
back okay I did a lot of damage here
yeah Denikin although
Wow
okay add this it's quite Tsubasa you
talk about her